hello everyone and welcome to today's
live broadcast aquaculture and
biomedical research of non-traditional
aquatics i'm brenda kelly kim and i'll
be your moderator from lab roots for
today's event
we have a few important announcements
before we begin
this webcast is designed to be
interactive and we encourage you to ask
questions during the event you can
submit questions by typing them in the q
a box which can be found by clicking on
the green q a button at the lower left
of the presentation window we'll try to
answer as many questions as we can
you can enlarge the slide window
by clicking on the screen icon in the
lower right hand corner of the slide
window
if you have any technical problems
viewing or hearing this presentation
please click on the support button at
the top right of your presentation
window or submit your question through
the green q a button lower left
would now like to introduce our speaker
dr dan rothen received his dvm from the
university of florida he has been a
clinical veterinarian at the university
of miami for 11 years
here he serves as a more traditional
laboratory animal veterinarian while
still maintaining veterinary
responsibility for the university's
aquaculture programs and non-human
primate medicine and surgery
he also consults with aquaculture
facilities throughout south florida
including coral restoration projects at
the mote marine laboratory in summerlin
florida
i will now turn it over to dr rovin for
his presentation
all right
hello everyone and uh thank you for for
tuning in um a couple things i'd like to
to say thank you to bio conference live
and lab roots for inviting me i really
appreciate the opportunity to speak to
to you guys today uh particularly rachel
don and brenda who've been very patient
and helped me with some technical
support appreciate that
and before i get started i want to
encourage everybody to also uh view the
webinar by dr juan ramos
it was earlier today on fish welfare
stress pathology
handling and managing
i found it to be very complementary to
the talk that i'm going to give today so
i highly recommend that you watch that
as well i know it was well done and a
lot of the same sort of ideas are
covered today that um in my slides that
he covered as well
so
like i said today's talk is on
aquaculture and biomedical research of
non-traditional aquatics so no zebrafish
and no xenopus will be discussed in this
presentation for the most part
um i'm from the university of miami
division of veterinary resources and uh
the picture you see on the the first
slide is just a couple of days ago down
in the florida keys and i just wanted to
let everybody know what february in
south florida looks like
so our objectives for today's
presentation will be to highlight unique
issues when you know using these
uncommon aquatic species we want to talk
about some thoughts on planning and
design of aquatic facilities and some of
the challenges that we have in staying
compliant with regulations and
and some suggestions that are created
for other species
as you know the the newest edition the
eighth edition of the guide for the care
and use of laboratory animals along with
the 2013 edition of the avma guidelines
for euthanasia have a much much larger
commentary about aquatics and aquatic
use
but for the most part you know those are
those are written for for our
traditional species so
there are some challenges and with some
of these unique species to stay
compliant with regulations that maybe
were created
for other situations and we'll talk a
little bit about oversight and
management
from the veterinary side and from the
technical side
so the first question i always like to
ask people say fish are fish right
and the answer that is of course no
the census of marine life has estimated
that there's 250 000 marine organisms
already described and seven hundred and
fifty thousand yet to be described so
that's it's a quite a a variation in in
fresh water and brackish water
approximately 126 000 species have been
described so
there's lots and lots of variation
one of my big pet peeves and something
uh that you'll see all the time is in
big box pet stores and this this picture
kind of highlights um
my my pet peeve if you will
all of these fish in big box pet stores
are on the same aquatic system they're
on a recirculating system however and
this picture you can see on the left
are some nice assorted african cichlids
and on the right
are some central american cichlids so
uh the african cichlids typically prefer
hard water and a higher ph whereas
essential american cichlids would prefer
a lower ph in a softer water condition
but in the big box pet store they're all
in the same water so
i'm not sure anybody's really happy in
that situation
and
a lot of times aquarists and hobbyists
kind of get confused with
thriving versus surviving so these fish
can certainly survive in this water but
we want our research animals and our our
uh our aquatics to really thrive so it's
going to be important to really
understand the fish that we fish that we
use
so when we talk about strategic planning
you know the first thing like everything
else location location location
we're also going to talk about emergency
plans and then a catastrophe plan and
kind of what the difference between
those two things is
we'll talk a little bit about water
source and where we can get water for
our animals and where are we going to
get our feeds and and what kind of
different variations uh in feed sources
we have available to us and then again
where do you get your animals i mean um
it's it's not too difficult uh to
acquire xenopus and zebrafish but some
more exotic species may be a bit of a
challenge to acquire
and then some of the things to think
about is study duration versus
infrastructure you know is it worth
spending hundreds of thousands of
dollars building a facility
for a short-term study or or maybe a
single pi and um there's some different
options on how to handle that
when we talk about location uh coastal
facilities have a great advantage
because we have an unending supply of
seawater it's very helpful but that
raises some other issues how do you get
water from the ocean to your animal
housing
or from from from a large lake to your
animal housing however you are
and then you know say you can get water
how do you filter it
and then do you know that the incoming
water is safe or and will it stay safe
you can test it um in in one part of the
year and then test it different part of
the year and and perhaps some values
have changed
we know that temperature has a big
effect and in our case you know we have
a lot of storms that pass through south
florida so that can can churn up some
things on the bottom of the water and
and change our water quality issues so
it's something that
you have to kind of figure out
how to keep that water safe for our
animals
and then a big one for us is what to do
with the outgoing salt water and and
we'll talk a little bit about that in
just a few moments
so like i said coastal locations are
advantageous this is the university of
miami's marine campus this is a hatchery
side and you can see
in the distance that's biscayne bay
and there's plenty of salt water for all
we could possibly use
and and those are the tops of our um
our
our tanks and vats for our systems
when it comes to emergency plans first
of all do you have one
often uh we gonna talk about having
power back up because that's one of the
first things that goes
when we have a problem and then when
when the power goes a lot of other
things go including water pumps and and
temperature
um
regulation things like that
oxygen is a little bit easier because we
can run oxygen through tanks
and through an air stone and that
doesn't require electricity
but it's still good to have some oxygen
on hand in the event of a short-term
emergency
and then what do you do with carcasses
uh this is a big issue with with large
fish you know zebrafish
are pretty small i'm sorry i said i
wouldn't talk about zebra fish but
we have some other small fish that we
use but when you're dealing with a 20
kilogram mahi mahi
or something like that uh you can't just
dispose of that carcass in the municipal
trash if that animal has been
euthanized with ms triple two then
it is a it is a problem so
we typically
see treat the big fish like we would a
swine or other large animals and and
have those incinerated by uh by a
private company
we do not allow those to go into
municipal waste
and we do not leave them out for for
other animals to
to come across
and one thing when it comes to emergency
and this is something that i harp on
with all hobbyists as well is having
redundancy
if you have a
one filter on your on your system and it
happens to go kaput
now you're in a lot of trouble so it's
oftentimes advantageous to have a
redundant system so that way if one
filter crashes you still have a time
with your other filter running to keep
the system in gear
this is kind of the back side of
our hatchery setup you can see there's
multiple water pumps and sand filters
and all kinds of plumbing
and the question is do you have backup
for that you know all those things
require power
those water pumps require power and
it's really is really really important
that you have backup power available
or something to
accommodate you should you run out of
power
or have one of those pumps break
so then
kind of on a grander scale is a
catastrophe plan and another thing do
you have one
we we have one because we have a
lot of hurricanes that either hit us
directly or try to scare us a little bit
but you know catastrophes can be fires
floods earthquakes
it's all over the country so nobody's
really immune to to having some
catastrophic event happen at their
facility
one option is it is to move animals um
you know we're very fortunate
with hurricanes that we have typically a
few days or or even a week's notice so
we can have joint agreements with
related facilities across the state
both north uh and uh and and west of us
so depending on the track of the storm
we would be able to move some large
animals
or large fishes i should say
to other facilities should we have an
impending hurricane
there's not many facilities south of us
because we're at the bottom of florida
but
we do have some agreements with related
facilities uh and you should also talk
about worst case scenarios what happens
if your entire facility gets gets
obliterating it's flattened um that's a
that's a big concern i'll show a picture
in a moment of how that can happen
you should also identify who your first
responder team is um in the event that
um you know some of these unexpected
things like fires and and floods
or earthquakes happen who's going to be
the first one to go check on those
animals now
you know at the university of miami we
have a hurricane team that goes into
effect every hurricane season so we're
pretty pretty good about that but
you know you just want to make sure you
identify those individuals so that way
there is no problems should one of those
emergencies happen my catastrophes
happen
and then the final thing and we'll talk
about this a little bit later in the in
the presentation is species selection
because if
your outdoor facility happens to get
flattened and all of your
fish gets swept out to sea well that's
kind of an important thing because uh we
want to make sure that we're not
introducing species that aren't supposed
to be there and we'll talk about that as
well
um some of you can remember hurricane
andrew in 1992 i promise you if you
lived anywhere in florida you really
remember hurricane andrew of 1992.
in this picture you can see it hit
pretty close to miami we were very
fortunate in the sense that
it hit about 30 miles south of our our
aquatic facility
still did a considerable amount of
damage
we also had some other large animal
facilities down south that sustained
significant damage
and um and certainly uh the people that
live down there um you know went through
catastrophic damage but it's not that
hard for a storm to come and hit us
directly so
it can happen and it happened in 1992
and i wouldn't be surprised if it
happens in the next few years so it's
important to have all of these things
planned out and strategized
when we talk about species selection
it's important to consider when we're
planning for these catastrophic events
like i said
we want to make sure that
we don't release any invasive or
non-native species due to accidental
release
it's somewhat analogous to the florida
everglades python problem which i'm sure
most people across the country have
heard about and know about
it's a butt of a lot of jokes but it's a
real big problem here and it's not just
pythons it's lots of other things
other reptiles fishes plants yeah you
name it everything grows in florida
so it's really important that you're
careful with the species that you select
and of course there are non-native
invasive species that live all over the
country
you know people want to do research on
snake heads or something like that you
want to make sure that those facilities
are nowhere near natural waterways
because those fishes can be very very
dangerous uh when they get into those
waterways
so so local species are always
preferable but
if you
if you're you're a researcher or
investigator wants to use um you know
something like a snakehead or something
then you just have to make sure that
there's no way that that animal could
make it into a natural waterway
some extra
barriers for outdoor facilities
just even some fencing can help
now i'm not saying that a fence is going
to stand up to hurricane andrew but
it certainly can help should there be
a large tank that ruptures or something
like that in the middle of the night
doesn't even have to take an emergency
sometimes
um shifts in the ground can be enough to
crack a
you know an 18 ton
vat or an 18 ton tank and if that
happens you know you can actually get a
fish release so
fences help keep the fish
inside the facility instead of into the
waterway
obviously it's not good for the fish but
it's good for the ecosystem
you can also have outflow pumps filters
and wells and that's how we do a lot of
our
outflow so it's to prevent accidental
release of
species and things like that
so
this is a picture i took while down in
the keys and these are just a number of
common fishes that are caught in monroe
county bridges i mean there's a million
of them so
there's lots of opportunities for for
marine research
when you're on the coast i mean there's
groupers and snappers and pompano and
hogfish and mackerel and triggerfish so
there's lots and lots of of native
species at least in south florida that
can be used for for research in
in an outdoor facility and so it's
important to know what exactly is in
your area and and try to use those
species or try to encourage researchers
to use those species
one thing you may or may not have heard
about and we'll talk about a little bit
more uh is our good friend the lionfish
and this is a become a real big problem
here in south florida due to
unintentional release and there's some
debate as to where it came from but
as somebody who's
dived the the florida keys for
most of my life
i can say that i hadn't seen them at all
ever outside of a pet store up until a
few years ago
and now
it's very common probably every other
dive you're going to see one or two
or more so
this is a new problem in south florida
and we'll talk a little bit more about
that in just a moment
when we talk about water sources like i
said location is helpful but it's not a
deal breaker
there's lots of uh different sources of
marine water
preferably is natural
just from the cost perspective
but you can reconstitute marine water
there's lots of salts available and you
can create a marine environment just
like the hobbyists do in your own
facility so there's no reason that you
couldn't be you know far far from the
coast maybe in the the midwest or
something like that and still run a high
quality marine
research system
it just might be a little bit more
costly so it's a one of those things
that you should add into your budget um
because creating your own salt water
gets pricey
now
when we talk about fresh water systems
uh it's pretty much the same options as
zebrafish facility um again i said i
wouldn't mention that but i'm doing it
twice
you can have municipal water reverse
osmosis water
you know pretty much any any water
source
that's fresh water you can create to be
habitable for fresh water fish you just
need to know uh your species is optimal
water quality and uh make sure that you
match that and and like i said it's very
different you've got um some fish that
like very hard water very high ph water
uh and and then you've got other more
sensitive fish that like soft water and
a low ph so that's really important to
know they're optimal water quality
parameters because um you're going to
get the best data possible
by having the the best environment so
that's totally analogous to
our mice and rats and other lab animal
species is trying to optimize
everything in their environment
lots of different water sources for us
here at the university of miami um you
can see in the in the background that's
a deep well that's pulling salt water
from below the limestone uh south
florida and most of florida in general
sitting on a big piece of
limestone rock and that well goes really
really deep and because it's so close to
the coast it actually pulls salt water
and that's pretty close in in quality to
the water that's in the the bay right
behind it so uh the advantage of that is
because it's so deep it's very unlikely
to contain pathogens and things like
that has been filtered to the limestone
but like all deep wells it's going to
have high pressure gases so there's a
degassing component to it as well but
that picture is a like i said a deep
well pulling salt water uh for us and we
use that throughout our system
other systems we have we have water
intake directly from biscayne bay and
you can see uh on the upper left picture
there's some tubes that kind of run
along the ground and then they go out to
a little stand where there's a bunch of
cormorants drying their wings
and that's where we have water intake
and once the water gets pumped from that
location
it goes into these settling vats which
you see on the bottom right
and
it's a series of chambers where uh
sediment can can slowly fall out of
solution so by the time the water gets
to the other end it's pretty free of
particulate matter now it's not
completely free but uh it's considerably
less than uh than it is when it's first
pumped in and that's helpful because it
prolongs the life of your filters
because um you know the water that comes
straight out of the bay with all the
particulates and things is going to clog
your filters pretty quickly
and so
what you don't see in that picture is
that there's a another side of it
but i didn't take a picture because it
was full of grad students shoveling up
uh debris um so once in a while you
gotta you gotta have them clean out all
the all the stuff that is sunk from from
the water
water alpha is also a real big concern
so we talked about you know getting
water to your animals well how do we get
water away from our animals and marine
systems are more challenging
there's a couple of different things
that we utilize here at the university
of miami we have a natural release
system that involves some filtration
some pumps
and then that water goes out to a
designated area
for natural release
i put in sewer system
because depending on the amount of water
that you're talking about sewer system
might be might be possible but uh for
the amount of water that we use at the
university us it is not uh legal for us
to use uh the sewer system for water
effluent the salt water
just overwhelms the the sewer system and
overwhelms the the reclamation
and cleaning
but when you think about the water
outflow you got to think that you know
you're only you know water is not the
only concern that you have you've got
hormones that could be used on these
animals you've got medications perhaps
our good friend ms-222
and then of course unintended release of
non-native species and pathogens so all
of those things need to be thought about
and planned about when you talk about
outflow of water you can't just uh go
ahead and dump it back into into the bay
without some some forethought in in some
you know potential different plumbing or
some filtration systems
we also have a deep water well that we
can um have outflow into
so a lot of things get diluted before
they would ever reach
any any
living organism
but uh the take-home point for this
slide is that it's absolutely critical
to work with your environmental health
and safety office and your local
government so that you can ensure safe
disposal of wastewater the last thing
you want to do is go through the trouble
of developing a beautiful system
and then have the county or the the
state tell you that uh you can't dispose
of the water that you have now uh added
into the system
so i touched on this a little bit
earlier um we now have the atlantic
lionfish
this is an accidentally released
species and there's some various uh
theories as to how that happened i won't
touch on that particularly here but you
can email me we can chat about it if you
like
but like i said you know i never used to
see them diving years ago but now you
see them all the time in fact uh down at
mote marine laboratory
and you can see there's one coming up on
february the 7th
they have lionfish around us or a
lionfish derby and
it's a contest and they have people go
out and and they oftentimes get 500
lionfish in a day uh it's really
shocking to see 500 lionfish
just kind of piled up and and and uh
you know removed from from the ocean in
one day it's really quite a sight to see
and i wish i had a picture of that
um unfortunately when it comes to the
lionfish manual removal will never
eradicate this species
as much as we want to try it's not going
to it's not going to be the be-all
end-all
recent studies have found lionfish at
waters that are deeper than traditional
divers go so the lionfish have learned
how to
get away from people
and uh here in the atlantic they're an
apex predator so the only people that
the only thing that really uh gets them
is humans and
like i said in the last point
fortunately they're quite delicious
so that's a that's a positive so that'll
encourage people to to collect those and
try to remove them
just got to remember that the spines on
top of the the back are poisonous and
will sting the heck out of you but you
can you can get around that the meat is
fabulous and in fact
reef.org and mote marine even have a
lionfish cookbook which you can get on
amazon
or anywhere else so there's lots of good
recipes and if you happen to take a
vacation down to the keys
you can oftentimes find lionfish on the
menu so that's kind of cool
we talk about our research animals
we talk about feed sources there's some
basic diets that are available
commercially
purina makes some missouri pentair
aquatic ecosystems cargill
many many more but the question is are
they right for your species of choice
you know here's a quick slide i took
from the purina website uh they've got
some fish feeds and and you know they've
got starter feeds they've got fry powder
they've got some for pond fish uh which
i'm assuming are are catfish type um and
then they've got a sport fish diet but
what does that really mean and is that
adequate for the the species that you
you choose
very possibly it is it could be it could
be absolutely perfect for what you need
but the bottom line is you need to
decide and learn what you need for your
species
otherwise you're giving them a
sub-optimal diet but there are lots of
options out there and like i said
the the the big guns like purina do make
diets that could be very well
used in in most facilities
however
like i said they're
these diets are available but they're
very species dependent especially when
we're talking about marine fish because
there's there's so many species out
there
as dr
ramos pointed out earlier today
we talk about herbivores carnivores
omnivores
i didn't know the word for fish study
coral coral wars if you will
and a good example of that is a
parrotfish and a parrotfish is a
gorgeous beautiful
tropical fish here that lives on the
reefs and when you die you hear them
crunching coral all day long and there's
some debate as to whether or not they're
actually eating the coral or if they're
just crunching the coral to get to the
algae that is inside but nevertheless
if you had a researcher that wanted to
to use parrotfish
that's something you'd have to keep in
mind and find a way to provide
at least some
some coral material for them to crunch
on and that may be a
big big hassle
because corals aren't the easiest thing
to get your hands on
and of course we also got to talk about
life stage and this goes with with all
sorts of of animals you know first foods
versus adult diets and and they're very
different
um
even our large fish start off as small
tiny fry um hatching from eggs so
they've got to be fed some of the same
things that that our other fish
are fed as well uh at the very beginning
but once these fish grow into
you know large fishes which we'll see
some videos of in shortly um you've got
to get the bait type fish um so you know
to to accommodate a large colony of
cobia or or mahi mahi
you oftentimes have to use frozen bait
type
operations
and get fish from them so that's a
little bit of a concern is it a
biosecurity risk of course it is um and
so
that's a that's a big big problem and
it's something that that we test for and
we're starting to do a lot more research
in because we don't know where you know
billy's baits are or any of these places
are getting these these fishes and squid
from uh they could be imported from from
asia for all we know so we want to make
sure that we're not introducing exotic
uh viral diseases
or things like that so that's something
that we really got to think about
especially in large operations
so some examples of herbivores
most people have heard of the grass carp
or the triploid grass carp if you will
they uh are incredibly good at eating
plants which is why they're triploid and
uh they're released into
into waterways that are overgrown
but the triploid grass carp can't
reproduce so
the same number you put in should be the
same number you could take out um and
they do a tremendous job and as you can
see in the picture on the right
they get huge and
a fish like that can mow down quite a
lot of vegetation very quickly and and
but they don't have to be you know giant
car you know even this beautiful yellow
eyed coal tang on the bottom uh is an
herbivore and it's just important to
know that that thing
needs a lot of vegetative matter as well
carnivores
are also commonly used and they don't
always have to be you know scary sharks
these are images from
one of our shark research programs here
at the university of miami the r.j
dunlap marine conservation program
and we do a lot of shark research but
carnivores don't all come in scary
shapes like these
you can have everything from the little
piranha on the left he's got a fish in
his mouth same thing with the oscar on
the right he's got a fish in his mouth
um
now the good thing is is a a fish like
an oscar can can easily be trained to
take a pelleted diet so that makes life
a lot easier but fish on the bottom is a
peacock bass and that is um
it's not native to south florida but
it's one of the few species that's been
introduced by the state to control the
release of exotic species it has some
very strict temperature limits so it
can't really escape and go much past
south florida so um they
they have been stocked in a lot of the
canals to avoid people dumping pet fish
into the into the canal because uh they
do quite a good job of removing them
they also are a lot of fun to go fishing
for so
those guys probably would have a harder
time
going onto a pelleted diet
i would say that those are probably
going to have to eat live feeds or or
some sort of frozen feeds which of
course comes back to the whole
biosecurity risk
i also have omnivores
and the beautiful discus on the left
it's not my picture but i've had discus
for years and i can tell you that during
the day they're gentle and beautiful and
just nibble on algae here and there
but as soon as the lights go out they
turn into something altogether different
and i've watched them just really do
some serious damage to my cardinal
tetras so uh they're omnivorous
uh fishes um even though they're they
seem peaceful and calm and uh things
like that they can
they need some some real uh
meat in their diet as well
on the bottom right is one of my
favorite fish
in all of the aquarium hobby it's a
green phantom plecostomus and most
people think of plicos as uh algae
eaters and sucker fish and things like
that but they actually require
vegetable and meat-based foods so
it's important that just because uh your
vendor or your pet store that sells you
these fish tells you that it's an algae
eater that doesn't mean that he's not
going to need other things besides that
so again it goes back to knowing
knowing about your fish
for juvenile feeds
we start with microalgaes and rotifers
and copepods
brine shrimp or
artemia
and you can see that we're growing them
in these large cylinders
that's kind of an old picture on the top
since our our population has grown here
at the university of miami we now use
the vats on the bottom to grow even more
of these uh juvenile feeds
the rotifers and co-pods and microalgae
are critical to the success of growing
out new species
in just a second i'm going to show you a
video um of some florida pompano
juveniles eating live feeds you'll see
they're getting fed some artemia towards
the end of the video and one thing i
want to tell you guys is that uh i
promise you that the video is normal
speed despite where it appears they are
the quickest little buggers you ever
seen so
we'll go ahead and show that video
so
okay
and that uh that tank is about uh
you know a little over
uh 3300 gallons and
you can see that there's thousands and
thousands of fish in there and uh
they're
they they love to eat those little guys
are pretty exciting
um when it comes to adult feeds it's a
little bit more of a challenge you know
because again we go back to being
species dependent and so it's in general
a good idea to provide multiple fresh
foods so that way
you get more of a balanced diet
assuming that you can't feed them
pellets or things like that
we do do some feed trials where we're
trying to
get some of our some of our animals onto
pelleted diets um but you know taking a
wild animal and converting them to a
pelleted diet can be a bit of a
challenge and and there's a lot of
research involved in that
ones that we use are typically are squid
sardines shrimp and herring but it can
be a lot of other things can be crabs
can be lobster lots of other
fresh foods depending on the species
that you've selected
in this next video i'm going to show
these are our cobia brood stocks so
these are um
pretty large fish
they're anywhere from i would say 10 to
30 kilos and
i apologize in advance for the the
camera kind of going in and out of the
water the problem is is with cobia that
they're very excitable fish so like a
bunch of puppies
and they will attack anything they'll
attack a camera they'll attack a
dissolved oxygen meter if you drop your
pencil in there they will attack that
they will attack your hand they will
attack anything that moves
they're pretty exciting uh in this
particular video you'll see they're
being fed whole fish but again i
apologize for the the camera coming in
and out of the water they're just trying
not to lose the gopro
oh
so in that video you can see there's
probably 10 uh 10 or 12
adult um cobia in there and they do
really well together i mean that's part
of their their nature and um
in a moment i'll show you some mahi mahi
which have different behaviors
cobia tend to be although they they do
go around florida and they do
travel quite a bit they hang around
structures and they come in schools very
often times
but the the mahi-mahi you'll see are
very different
so in this video
we're going to be feeding some mahi
some squid but i want you to notice the
number of fish per tank
and the reason that is is
a big bull or a big male mahi
will easily kill other male mahi and
oftentimes kill female mahi
so
you really have to find the delicate
balance between the right number of
animals and then the ability to breed
so it's a bit of a challenge but you'll
see that there's only a couple of them
in this giant tank and
this is a an 80 ton tank so it's 22 000
gallons and look at how many fish we
have in there so let's go ahead
no
so even that even that big male came
over to check us out um
they're
they're they're quite a an amazing
species and uh unfortunately
we're working on ways to
to be able to have more of them per tank
and work on some of the aggression
issues um but you know that's the way
that they live uh they live in deep
water and uh although they like
structure and they do school there's
plenty of space for fish to get away
from each other in the natural habitat
uh as opposed to the cobia which are
typically a more shallow species
and don't have
the same options to escape
the big bad
macho man
so with these
unusual species we talk about where we
get them from what are our sources well
aquaculture is obviously a great place
to start and a lot of species are are
grown maybe not in your area but they're
grown somewhere
in aquaculture is ideal
but if not then you can go with a wild
caught and sometimes the investigator is
the one that can catch them however when
it comes to regulations
we want to make sure that the the pis
have the right permits
and this is something that we ask for in
our protocol reviews is permits and
special activity licenses of the
state of florida thing and and just to
make sure that they're not in protected
areas or getting
protected species or anything like that
to help both every about the
investigator and the university uh stay
compliant with with legal regulations
and then you know when the pi catches
them how are they catching them are they
catching them by net by hook and line
versus the fish trap
all of those have um different levels of
potential pain and distress
as dr ramos also
touched on earlier today
one way that we've also gotten fish is
purchasing from professional local
fishermen
i specifically underlined professional
because you don't want the guys that are
sitting on top of the bridge yanking up
whatever they catch
that's not an acceptable way to collect
animals however
the fishing guides
really really know their stuff and they
can go out they know where the the fish
are they know where they are in
different times of season
and most likely they have the ability to
bring that animal back to you
in in a very high
and i'm sorry in a very safe um and and
and professional way
as opposed to you know some guy with a
bucket on the side of the road
and then in uh other scenarios you can
purchase some aquatic importers
lots and lots of fish are are bred
overseas particularly in asia
but of course when you're doing
international importation there are
other issues that can arise as well um
both with travel and with exotic disease
so that's a you know i would say that's
kind of a lower on my my options list
but
some other planning considerations
when you're building a new facility is
how many studies are going to utilize
this infrastructure again it's not worth
spending hundreds of thousands of
dollars um for a short-term study with
one pi um there are ways to to make
temporary facilities right and um
and to to accommodate pis
but if you're going to if you're going
to build a large facility and really try
to incorporate that into your university
or into your um into your institution
some things you got to worry about or
think about is who's going to manage
this and and i don't mean um
just the fish but the infrastructure um
and do you have the people that know how
to uh fix the equipment do they
understand how water works in in in
these situations and and
um who's gonna who's going to be able to
fix that water pump on christmas eve
when it breaks down so
that's important thing and then of
course who's going to manage the animals
this is always a big debate when it
comes to the veterinary side and the
husbandry side
because a lot of veterinarians don't
have experience with aquatics and and so
you've got to decide who's going to
manage those animals
um from from a health perspective as
well
and then of course is the facility cost
effective and that's when i talk about
permanent versus temporary so
there are lots of uh aquaculture pools
um they look like little pop-up pools
that you get for your your children um
and you can turn that into a very
successful uh aquaculture setup that you
could take down when not in use
we talk about housing systems they're
very similar again between freshwater
and marine systems
we've got a flow-through system which
most people know about it's kind of
water in to the fish
and then water out
not a whole lot of filtration is going
on in the actual tank itself it's just a
fresh supply of clean water and
we have that at the university
we also have recirculating systems and
recirculating systems are very very
classic that's what you see with xenopus
systems and
fish stores and
most people's personal aquariums things
like that so recirculating is very
common
and especially in areas where you don't
have an over abundance of salt water um
you really have to go with a
recirculating system but you can use the
same equipment and the same you know
set up the sump and the pump and
everything can be the same for a
recirculating system both in fresh water
and in salt water
sometimes there's a mix of both and we
have that as well
and then
one other housing system we'll talk
about in just a second uh is aquaponics
i won't touch too much on that but i'll
show you some some things that we're
doing here at the university
uh this is a picture of a classic
flow-through system um there'll be a
video after this slide i'll show you um
but uh in this particular picture you
can see these are these are juvenile
cobia that are probably if i had to
guess a couple of months old
and
they're swimming uh against the current
as you can see they're all kind of
pointed in the same direction the white
pvc in the center is the stand pipe
and what that does is that controls the
depth of the water so if you were to
pull that out all the water will
disappear it will go down
and that allows you to do a couple of
things
one when the fish are not there allows
you to empty the system very quickly and
easily and clean it
for the next round
it also allows you to put a different
height
pvc pipe in there so that way if you had
to treat the animals with an anesthetic
or
you know any sort of chemical
you can lower the amount of water so
therefore you lower the the use of the
drug that you're trying to
utilize on those animals
so uh in a second i'm going to show you
a video of some baby mahi mai you've
already seen the mom and dad
but
we've got a bunch of juveniles inside
and
what's interesting is you can see some
of that
male aggressive behavior actually
even when they're this size and so um
sometimes we have to remove some of the
larger more aggressive males even when
they're very young because they're just
they're just the they're just tough guys
and and they can become problematic but
you'll see the stand pipe
right in the middle that's the pvc and
you'll see the water flow as well and
that's a very typical setup
for us and for a lot of other
aquaculture facilities
so please
i'll show that
to me they're they're they're gorgeous
they're they're really amazing and the
the colors that you see uh the videos
don't do it justice when you see them uh
up close and in real life they're
they're stunning even when they're uh
less than an inch the the colors really
just bounce out of them and they're
they're gorgeous animals but you can see
in that video that uh that standpipe is
what controls the the height of the
water and uh all the water is flowing
down on the other side or i'm sorry
inside of that pvc pipe
um recirculating systems which we
touched on before they don't have to be
you know small uh aquari aquarius type
or xenopus housing type they can be
these gigantic vats
and the videos you saw earlier of the
cobia and the mahi
broodstock are large animals
they're in there in these giant tanks
and we've got
sand filters we've got a heater chiller
mechanism we've got all kinds of
filtration going on so that system is
totally a recirculating system
and
that
that
that tank has its own recirculating
system um so it's all enclosed in one
whereas in this next slide you'll see
that this is kind of more analogous to
um our other species and pet stores
where you've got multiple tanks that are
on the same water system they're all
connected you can't see the filter in
this particular picture but uh they're
they're all connected so
that has its own issues in the sense
that if there's a disease outbreak in
one tank you've got a disease outbreak
in all tanks but it also allows
one filter to control all of those
different
different tanks
here's a quick picture of our aquaponics
system at the marine campus in the very
bottom white vat we've got blue tilapia
and the whole idea of aquaponics is that
as you feed the the fishes they produce
nitrogenous waste and nitrogenous waste
are just what
basil and tomatoes and and things like
that love to love to eat so um we
actually produce quite a bit of our
food for the cafeteria over there or at
least some of the greens from the
cafeteria in aquaponics system so
it's kind of a unique way and
i think it's pretty cool and i think
it's really going to be
kind of a wave of the future when it
comes to food production because it
allows you to kind of maximize
production of both plants and fishes at
the same
time we talk about water quality
parameters and testing again completely
species dependent um you got to know you
got to know what you're dealing with and
the parameters tested and the frequency
really depends on the type of system
you've chosen flow through is different
than recirculating and what you need to
look for and where your water is coming
from
one thing that we have done at the
university of miami to kind of make
things a little easier for us is that in
our i cook protocols we ask the pi
to talk about their water quality
testing and their frequency and and what
that allows us to do is should the pi
deviate from that um in a in a negative
way uh that gives the us our ayakook or
oversight body the ability to get
involved
and have a little more more oomph and
get them on board to do what they say
they're going to do
but one thing i want to remind people
is that oftentimes with these exotic
species
the pis
are
are often the experts you know they they
have been studying uh the florida
pompano
for 25 years they know more about it
than anybody else
so it's really important that
we have their input and uh we we have to
have a really congenial relationship
with our aquatic pis um and the iacook
and the veterinary staff so that way um
you know we're on the same team because
they really know what they're doing we
may know the the regulations but they
they know the biology of the fishes
and when it comes to water quality
parameters and testing it's not always
uniform between pi's and systems so
we have lots of different
options if you will depending on
the system that you're running
here at the university
again when we talk about i cooking and
oversight body compliance
it's challenging because most iacook
members don't know anything about
aquatics
is a natural thing
one thing that has been a hot topic for
us is how do we characterize pain and
distress
is capture collection and travel
distressful
we have determined that uh
you know it is can potentially
distressful to
to pull a fish from the bottom of the
ocean with a hook in its mouth um so we
actually use the usda pain in distress
categories and
for wild caught fishes like that we we
call them category e um but at a local
um i'm sorry at a recent i cook 101 301
i i asked this particular question um
and the answer was well why are you
using the usda pain and distress
categories anyway so that's a good point
so you don't actually have to use
those categories but for the university
of miami we do use
the usda pain and distress categories
for all of our animals despite their
lack of usda oversight
just to make it easier on everybody but
we personally have considered wild
collection for the most part to be
category e or potentially distressful
as you can imagine
so again advantageous to have water
quality testing regimen stated in the
protocol
and it's also important that the pi
documents mortalities we would ask the
same sort of thing of a mouse producer
or uh you know mouse user um just so we
have an idea of where we're at in terms
of numbers and we can identify when
there are our mass mortalities or or
some
maybe even a slow steady increase in
mortality of animals
however
one thing i will warn you uh is that
expect some pushback from the aquatic
scientists
as our regulations for laboratory animal
care increases you know we i talked on
one of the first slides about um how
this is aquatics are a bigger part of uh
our regulations now uh and a lot of
aquatic scientists are not used to being
told um kind of what to do and what they
have to do so um it's it's not the
easiest thing but um i think with some
mutual respect uh it can be uh it can be
a very positive relationship but they
just need to understand that uh you know
if you're using animals at the
university you fall under the the
guidance of the the i cook
and we need to keep them in in
regulatory compliance
when it comes to management issues who's
responsible for what again that's
important
per diems per damps can be a nightmare
because uh facilities have multiple
different pis they have different
systems and differing level levels of
involvement some pis will do 100 of
their animal care and we have some pis
that really want to be hands off and
they'll allow our staff to do it so
calculating per diem is is really a
hassle um difference like i said
different systems um you know a
recirculating system has consumables it
has filter pads it has charcoal it has
uv sterilizing bulbs things like that
whereas some of the the flow-through
systems don't have that
and so it's a it's a challenge to get
the right per diems um for for your
facility
and again um other management issues
predators and pests um it's critical to
know your local laws you know i would
say one of our biggest
potential predators are wading birds you
know a great blue heron or
any of any of these water birds would
love to just gobble up a bunch of baby
mahi mahi um but by law we cannot harass
or do anything um to those to those
birds so that's why you'll see all of
our tanks are covered uh or are under
shade of some sort so they just don't
have access to it
but it's really important that you know
your local law so that you don't
potentially harass or or or cause a
problem to you know a protected species
again we go back to carcass disposal
when we euthanize a
40 pound um or 40 kilo you know bull
mahi something you know delicious we
can't just throw it in a dumpster
because you know birds can find that or
or you know
homeless folks can find that and um may
think that they hit the jackpot and in
fact that's a that's a toxic animal so
we do carcass disposal um for our large
animals our large fishes the same way we
do with our large animals at the
university and that's commercial
incineration
however you can also donate fish to
other facilities you know a lot of uh
local aquariums would love to have
some some fish given to them
as long as they're healthy and free of
other problems so that's something to
think about as long as you have some uh
established uh parameters for that
of course like our rodent species we
also got to worry about environmental
monitoring and alarm systems you know
temperature is absolutely critical
um you know just like uh just like
rodents it can't get too cold it can't
get too hot
gotta have redundant heaters and
chillers depending on on on your
situation of course you gotta have extra
parts on hand and this is the same thing
with my home aquarium
my motto is if it can break it will and
at the worst time possible and that has
proven itself true more than once i can
promise you that
when it comes to veterinary issues do
you have a veterinarian
with experience or knowledge on staff i
mean that that in itself is a hard thing
to find you know fortunately um aquatics
are a bigger part of
veterinary education these days and a
lot of veterinarians are seeking out
some of this knowledge so and and
obviously some of you here watching
today and in the future uh are
interested in that so that's a great
thing so um we need to to improve on
that and get more aquatic veterinarians
out there
and again knowledge of the species is
absolutely critical
uh a lot of them a lot of these species
the physiologic values are lacking
nobody knows i mean i could draw blood
from
lots of different fishes but if we don't
know what a normal is we have no
we have no value in that sample also
normal appearance and behavior for
different species um you know um is is
that is that big mahi just a bully uh or
are all big male mahi that way well they
all are on that way again
knowledge of the species you know what
diseases should you be looking for and
this is very species dependent as well
and then of course what diseases are
reportable because just like uh in in
other industries cattle and and
and things uh we do have reportable
diseases and so you know fortunately
none of those have ever cripped up at
the university of miami but should they
creep up um
i would report those to the appropriate
authorities
it's also important to have a
biosecurity plan and that involves uh
everything from who enters the facility
to
how your your nets are handled to uh
food intake and there's lots of
different ways that pathogens can enter
your facility so if you if you've
thought about that
and made plans uh you're you're ahead of
the game
you also can get usda facility
accreditation even though these are not
usda covered species
if you're doing mass production you need
to have facility accreditation and that
can be done through usda aphis
if you're shipping these animals whether
they be eggs larvae whatever
you still need to have
the usda uh national veterinary
accreditation program category two
accreditation um and and know what
you're doing when it comes to
international shipping
um i always tell people that the
veterinarians are the liaison between
the researchers and the regulators you
know besides you know being in charge of
animal health
we're also in charge of keeping
everybody in compliance and of course
just like with any facility we should be
involved the veterinary team should be
involved in planning new construction
talk about research opportunities
you can do off culture for food
production pet production
research animal production and direct
biomedical research
when we come to food fishes
our brood stock are our most valuable
and critical animals those are the ones
that are the oldest
and the hardest to replace
and just keep in mind that it can take
more than a year
for some of these seasonally breeding
fishes and and it can take multiple
years because you've got a lot of steps
to accomplish you've got to produce
viable eggs so they've got a hatch
you've got to feed larvae
and get those larvae to to grow
in the f1s to become sexually mature and
then try to breed the f1 so
it can take a number of years for a
species that perhaps you're not used to
we typically ship eggs and larvae
sometimes juveniles and that's mostly uh
because it's a
it's a lot cheaper to ship a hundred
thousand eggs than it is to ship
just five giant broodstock cobia
something like that
um but when you whenever you're shipping
fish you gotta remember that you gotta
adhere to drug and chemical withdrawal
times which excuse me which are
established
in the literature and of course you need
usda veterinary inspection for shipment
um and if you're doing mass production
you need to have an aquaculture site
accreditation from the usda
you need to know and respect the current
regulations of the importing country if
international and this is really
important and i underline current
because oftentimes the regulations
appear as soon as you ask the country
what your regulations are
and i've got some funny stories to tell
people offline
where regulations didn't exist until i
asked about them um and uh when you get
really good at it sometimes it's easier
to work at it with a third party um to
sell those fishes
uh for pet production it's similar to
food fish but they're typically smaller
species there's a little bit less
concern about drug selection and
withdrawal times um because these are
not food animals but you still need usda
veterinary inspection for export you
still need site accreditation if you're
going to be a mass producer of these
animals i say when in doubt write a
health certificate never hurts to to
write a health certificate um
after you've examined those animals
and if you have questions contact the
usda aphis office
they're the experts
research animal production is again
highly dependent on species selected you
can have invertebrates or vertebrates
but even if you have invertebrates you
still need usda veterinary inspection
for international export and you still
need usda aquaculture site accreditation
for mass production
even for uh somaplegia which i'll talk
about in a second
for direct biomedical research these
fishes and animals are used for tumor
studies auditory research physio
physiologic testing genetics of wild
populations interactions between species
behavioral research in some pollution
studies both short and long term it's
kind of endless when it comes to
biomedical research
in this particular picture you can see
um it's a little bit tough but uh uh in
the middle uh you can see a bi-colored
damselfish we use those for tumor
studies um unfortunately we got to keep
them separated because they're highly
aggressive with each other but uh
they're used for tumor studies and
they're in a traditional uh
recirculating system this is a our brand
new facility and and uh you can see
there's many many many of them in here
and all this water is recirculated
another fish that we've used here at the
university of miami is the photos from
my friend dr lou
this is the jade gobi and these are used
a lot for auditory research
i used to inspect his facilities a lot
and i fell in love with the fish so much
that i have one in my own tank and uh
the one in my own tank is about four
times the size of the ones that you see
on the left so they're really really
groovy fish uh and they're and they're
fun to watch they have unique behavior
but they're using auditory research and
most people wouldn't think
that fishes are using auditory research
so just a moment i'm going to show you a
a young mahi that's in a swim chamber
in a swim chamber
can measure physiologic responses we can
count opercular movements and that can
give us some estimation of o2
consumption
and it's oftentimes related with images
that are captured by a high-speed
computer
and we can do analyses later
we can change the water from quick to
slow um we can change temperature
salinity all kinds of parameters and see
the effect or we can expose them to to
potential pollution or potential toxins
things like that
and uh the way we manage it is that we
kind of make it analogous to using a
treadmill in mice and rats so it's the
same sort of idea so you'll see this
little mahi swimming has swimming his
tail off so to speak
go ahead
so like i said that was a quick video
but you can see uh we can we can see uh
that animal and we can do a lot of a lot
of analyses uh with high-speed computers
um
we also are the university of miami is a
national resource center for applesia uh
apresia
is a
the california sea hare and they're used
a lot in neuroscience and we are the
nih's national center for research
resources with this species
here's some pictures of our setup on the
upper left is uh an adult
plegia californica
they can get to be about the size of a
football
so they're quite impressive when they're
big
and you can see in the other pictures
are set ups and
of course there are there there are no
real commercial setups for these so some
of you may recognize the polycarbonate
rat cages that are used uh in the in the
pictures so we're doing internal
recycling
of our rat cages to facilitate this
project um and uh on the bottom right as
you can see that's where we're growing
the the babies out from the eggs so it's
a pretty cool setup and uh we're real
happy about that real proud of that
facility
uh and the reason that we're so good at
it is because we've got sun and we've
got seaweed
so we can do this better than anybody
and that's just a picture of a vats that
are containing nothing but seaweed that
are a pleasure to eat like it's candy
so wrapping up some resources that are
available to you
from a diagnostic sense um i i've
utilized the university of florida um
usda athes
has a lot of information for aquaculture
if you're not in florida you know
contact your agricultural college
extension offices that's what they're
there for there's also professional
internet fish veterinary groups like uh
association of fish veterinarians
and when in doubt contact your local
veterinary school and they can help
point you in the right direction if you
want to do some some advanced
diagnostics maybe some pcr some virology
things like that
so take away points are you can do it um
it doesn't uh it doesn't take an expert
you can become an expert very quickly
and uh you know as long as you plan
ahead of time before you study and know
your species
you're really ahead of the game
and our aquatic systems share a lot of
the same similarities between marine and
freshwater facilities so
you may have a lot of experience with
you know zebrafish third time i've said
it
and if so that's fine you know you can
easily use a lot of that same experience
and same knowledge base to do pretty
much any marine species so long as you
do your homework beforehand
but just remember that there's often
sorry there are often little data on
most of our non-traditional species and
sometimes the pi is the expert so it's
it's important that we work together
with them and have a real positive
relationship with them um so just some
some quick acknowledgements um thanks to
dr julia zayas my director here at the
division of veterinary resources dr dan
binetti he's a director of aquaculture
here at the university of miami
lots of aquaculture folks especially ron
and john
have been just totally awesome and
helped me out a lot and my mentor dr roy
yannong
at the tropical aquaculture laboratory
at the university of florida um in that
picture you can see those are we call
them the a team that's our aquaculture
team and we're quite proud of their
accomplishments um and uh the they're
just an outstanding group of individuals
so thank you very much um i appreciate
your time we'll take some questions in a
second and uh again this is a a picture
of uh the keys in february so sorry
about uh everybody who's not
or who's battling the snow i should say
so i think
thank you very much dan for that great
presentation before we get started on
the question and answer session i would
like to remind our audience how to
submit questions
you can submit questions by typing them
in the q a box which can be found by
clicking on the green q a button at the
lower left of the presentation window
and we'll try to answer as many
questions as we can
our first question
we have from the audience
is i know this might not be related but
do you know if there is a strategy to
exterminate the lionfish i understand it
is quite invasive and it is negatively
impacting the fishing industry
um there there's lots of different uh
ideas out there um
you know but really uh at this point i
think it's uh it's just manual removal i
think that a lot of people are very
nervous and very scared because uh in
the atlantic this is an apex predator
and um they're
they're they're eating lots of reef
fishes and i don't think uh that
the the field really understands um
everything about how the lionfish has
adapted to the the atlantic you know
they're from the pacific and it's a
colder water species but they seem to
have tolerated um being here but their
ability to tolerate cold water allows
them to go a lot deeper so
i'm not sure that there's a real good
plan out there and i think that the
wildlife folks are really nervous about
it to be honest with you
great we do have another question at
what point do you think it would be
appropriate to grow your own live feed
for adult animals it would eliminate
your concerns for biosecurity
um
i would say that uh you know we grow our
own foods for for obviously for the
juveniles i i don't think it would be
particularly cost effective for um the
large fishes um
it could be done um but it would be it
would be very labor intensive and most
people don't have the space to grow out
the sheer numbers that we would we would
need um you know in our case so i think
you're really kind of uh you're kind of
stuck with these uh bait producers but
um
you know if if chance you found the
disease outbreak or or you were
concerned about that
or if you know you had a smaller
population of animals that's totally
reasonable to do um but if you're going
to be feeding live fish to other fish
that's something that your iacook needs
to know about and needs to make some
decisions on
because
getting eaten alive i think would be
potentially distressful
okay our next question if you have a
large sick fish and you collect a blood
sample for analysis do you have to
process that sample yourself or can you
send it to a contract lab
um you can send it to a contract lab i
mean you can do some processing yourself
it really depends on on you know your
facilities i mean i'm at a medical
school so i have a little bit more
options in other places but you could
certainly um collect blood and then and
then ship it you know the key is is to
talk to the laboratories beforehand uh
and and have some communication with
them for exactly what their capabilities
are and what they what they would want
but certainly you can do your own um
processing as well um but depending on
what your institution's capabilities are
for the most part um you know medical
schools don't have a lot of the the pcr
uh primers and things that you would
need for for fishes but um if you're at
a veterinary school or something like
that then you may have an internal
laboratory that would work but there are
a lot of third-party laboratories um
that can really help you out in that
situation so um it kind of depends on on
what you're doing
and where you're at
okay and we have our last question you
refer to biosecurity a lot with the
animals do you believe this is equally
important when it comes to selecting
your water source
yes and no
i certainly
i would prefer if i could make my own
water but um you know it's definitely a
concern um we we have had outbreaks of
uh external parasites before from
incoming water um that's happened on a
couple of occasions but for the most
part we don't have that issue
you know it is a potential risk but it's
something that we monitor regularly for
and if we were to have an outbreak of a
particularly viral disease or something
like that we would be easily be able to
isolate
the affected animals and then
test them and potentially
eradicate that pathogen but certainly
it's uh it's a concern
you know my biggest concern is is
external parasites because they're
they're so prevalent and uh the other
thing you know it's not quite bio
security but with incoming water is
um
you know there could be a toxin spill
you saw the the slide where the
collection is out in the bay uh there
could be some yahoo that decides to dump
uh
oil or or gasoline out of his boat right
there um and then that could potentially
get to our fishes but um
that's that's the things that worry me
the most so um biosecurity a little bit
but you know it's kind of difficult when
you're pushing you know hundreds of
thousands of gallons a day so
it can be a bit of a challenge
thank you dr rovin unfortunately we are
out of time i want to thank the audience
for their interesting questions and
their participation in today's event and
thank you dr rothen for all of your um
excellent videos and pictures today's
webcast will be available for on-demand
viewing through august 2015 and you'll
receive an email from lab roots alerting
you to when this webcast will be
available for replay we invite you to
pass this announcement along to your
colleagues who may have missed today's
live event
that's all for now goodbye and see you
next time